es ist an der zeit dass wir über das
thema botulismus reden falls du dieses
video hier dass ich letztes jahr gemacht
haben noch nicht gesehen hast tourismus
ist eine ziemlich gefährliche
lebensmittelvergiftung die man unter
anderem durch nicht fachgerecht ein
gekochte lebensmittel bekommen kann
deswegen ist es super wichtig dass sich
jeder draußen derselbe einkocht mit dem
thema botulismus auseinandersetzen
die botulismus bakterien die diese
lebensmittelvergiftung auslösen kann
kommt weil sie überall vorne sitzen auf
unserem gemüse seinen händen die sind in
der erde und so weiter das ist
eigentlich auch gar kein problem weil
diese pärchen erst richtig gefährlich
werden wenn sie unter luftabschluss sind
zum beispiel die bedingungen die in
einem einfach glasflaschen erst da
können wir loslegen und ihre toxine
produzieren die dann am ende so giftig
für uns sind aber jetzt sagt man nicht
willkommen das ganze jahr ab dann
sterben die bakterien und dann ist alles
gut aber pustekuchen
wir haben nämlich eine super power die
bilden nämlich spuren und diese spuren
sind super hitzeresistent die können
sogar temperaturen von 120 grad
aushalten unglaublich eigentlich gut
auch vor den kleinen kirchen aber das
ist für uns natürlich total doof weil
wir kochen was einstellen dass in den
schrank und dann keinen da auf einmal
diese spuren aus die bakterien vermehren
sich wieder in unseren gläsern teilweise
sogar ohne dass wir das bemerken weil
ein teil der module ismus bakterien auf
gar keine gase produzieren werden sie
sich in den lehrsaal vermehren das heißt
man kann das von außen gar nichts sehen
sie produzieren aber da dieses toxin und
das ist sehr sehr sehr giftig und ich
sagen jetzt vorweg das botulismus sehr
hessen ist das heißt die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass das passiert ist
nicht besonders groß und ich möchte auch
mit diesem video überhaupt keine panik
verbreiten das war in vielen kommentaren
die unter dem letzten video da gelassen
wurde so ein bisschen der tenor ich
finde es nur sehr sehr wichtig weiterhin
in deutschland so wenig leute sprechen
dass dieses wissen einfach publik
gemacht wird damit noch wichtig
einfachen kann bei einfachen ist eine
super sichere haltbarmachen methode wenn
man sich an die richtigen techniken hält
und eben die lebensmittel in denen sich
die populismus bakterien wohlfühlen so
einfach dass auch die spuren abgetötet
werden
und weil wir das thema so am herzen
liegt und weil ich ja selber auch gar
keine expertin bin ich bin da keine
lebensmittel biologin oder so was habe
ich mir für meinen onlinekurs obst und
gemüse haltbar machen einen experten mit
ins boot geholt das ist der andreas
stelle ich euch letzte mal vor der
erzählt noch ein bisschen mehr zum thema
botulismus und beantwortet auch ein paar
sehr knifflige fragen die wahrscheinlich
vielen von euch gerade auf der seele
brennen hallo andreas schön dass du da
bist von andreas arbeitet als
mikrobiologe wahrscheinliche was jetzt
erzählen ja ich arbeite seit 25 jahren
eine mikrobiologischen labor zur
lebensmittelkontrolle bin selber auch
ein großer garten kennen und findet
daher das thema haltbarmachen ein super
wichtiges thema ist ja und wo sind wir
beide im prinzip zusammen gekommen ich
habe auch wie in ihren videos gesehen
und da dachte ich mir da kann ich mal
unterstützen vor allem den grafen super
wichtiges thema ja das ist total danke
dass du da bist du jetzt kennen wir ihn
mit den ganzen fragen löchern sie ihren
74 und zylinder getragen maximal zählen
wie das abläuft so eine botulismus
erkrankt
botulismus erkrankung ist uns relativ
hinterhältig sage ich jetzt mal das
heißt man ist ein lebensmittel was
verdorben ist und die erste reaktion die
man die man hat es im prinzip dass man
müde davon wird na also man merkt
vielleicht hat das die ja dass das die
finger ein bisschen taub werden
aber die haupt
die jahre die at t die haupt behauptet
oben sage ich jetzt mal ist tatsächlich
dass man als alle ärzte erst mal müde
wird
weil das botulinumtoxin
auf das nervensystem im prinzip geht und
die muskeln anfängt zu nehmen das ist
dann auch eine gewisse müdigkeit hervor
dann denken die leute okay dann lege ich
mich ein bisschen hin noch häufig hat
man auch ein bisschen ein bisschen sie
beschwerden dann dabei ich habe mich
vielleicht etwas überarbeitet oder war
zu warm heute ich leg mich hier nun
schlafen runde und wenn die leute dann
wieder aufwachen dann ist es häufig
schon so weit dass sie die arme und
beine nicht mehr bewegen können weil das
allererste hat die extremitäten gelähmt
werden und die lähmung die kriegt dann
quasi immer weiter nach innen
deshalb letztendlich dann aber das herz
wäre das allerletzte was gelähmt werden
würde vorher wird aber die werden aber
die für die atmung erforderlichen
muskeln gelähmt und ja also mann er
fliegt dann tatsächlich bei vollem
bewusstsein also wesentlich unangenehmer
geht ein licht raum also dafür wollen
sie leicht machen ja doch auch alle
bilder
von dem wie viele lebensmittel muss man
aufnehmen das ist ja auch nicht viel
oder mal gelesen ein lasso würde
theoretisch schon ausreichen wenn der
kot urin um das botulinumtoxin
ja also das modellieren neurotoxin ist
das stärkste natürliche nervengift der
welt also von daher wenn wenn man eine
konserve hat wo diese botulismus
bakterien drin gewachsen sind und eine
gewisse menge toxin von schon gebildet
haben davon reichen tatsächlich einen
löffel also dieses dieses was man was
man früher gesagt hat ich kann ja mal
probieren ob gut ist kann zu viel sein
okay aber
bevor jetzt alle völlig ausflippen es
gibt eine möglichkeit um das ziemlich
sicher oder wirklich sicher zu
verhindern wenn man konserven im schrank
stehen hat wo man sich nicht ganz sicher
ist ob man die essen sollte oder nicht
wenn man die bevor man sie ist für zehn
minuten sprudelnd aufkocht richtig dann
werden alle toxine die da drin sein
könnt wenn genug
reaktiviert oder wie nennt man das im
prinzip werden sie werden sie den natura
teenager ist ja ist der fachausschuss
und zwar sind die spuren von dem von dem
populismus bakterien ist sehr sehr
hitzeresistent das gift allerdings nicht
das gift es auch an ein protein und
ja bei hitzeeinwirkung beginnt das zu
verfallen und dann ist das total harmlos
also damit ist man dann immer noch auf
der sicheren seite ich finde es aber
nicht so appetitlich die vorstellung
dass es da mal gewesen sein könnte
deswegen bin ich immer eher freund davon
dass gleich richtig zu machen aber bevor
man jetzt den ganzen schrank voll ein
gekochte sachen die man ja auch meistens
selber angebaut hat für wegschmeißt ist
das immer noch eine option hat das ganze
ist also ein sehr ernst zu nehmendes
thema aber ich finde das ist nichts was
eigentlich ein kochen abhalten sollte
weil es nämlich gar nicht so schwer ist
zu hause sicher einzukochen wenn man
einfach weiß welchen lebensmitteln man
welche technik verwenden sollte und
deswegen waren wir jetzt mal mit der
frage an welchen lebensmitteln muss man
denn überhaupt auf diese
tourismusgeschichte achten und das sind
alle lebensmittel die nicht so viel
säure enthalten weil wenn ein
lebensmittel sehr sauber ist dann fühlen
sich die botulismus bakterien davon
überhaupt nicht holen und dann können
sie sich davon auch nicht bei mehr als
obst könnt ihr absolut bedenken du bist
einfach so in einem wasserbad einkochen
in einem normalen kochtopf und so gut
wie alle gemüse fallen die anderen
kategorie wo man ein bisschen mehr
aufpassen muss genauso wie
fleischtomaten die genau auf der grenze
das kommt total auf die sorten an ja
ganz unterschiedlich aber sind deswegen
werde ich tomatensoße 1 woche gebe ich
immer ein bisschen zitronensaft mit dazu
um den ph-wert einfach ein bisschen
abzusenken und auf der sicheren seite zu
sein und das ganze im wasserbad
einkaufen zu können alle anderen gemüse
kocht nicht nur im druckkopf 1 das hier
ist ein spezieller druck ein kochtopf
von der firma presto macht das video wie
auch nicht weil ich die dinger verkaufen
möchte deswegen verlinke ich euch auch
keine unter dem video damit mir das
niemand vorwerfen kann wie im anderen
video wo ich auch keine verlinkt habe
also ich verdiene daran nichts das ich
euch das jetzt hier sage das ist einfach
einen topf der temperaturen von über 100
grad erreicht weil um die kleinen spuren
von denen ich euch erzählt habe
entledigen zu können um die auszuknocken
damit sie sich nicht mehr in unseren
lesern breit machen können müssen wir
temperaturen von 116 manchmal 120 grad
erreichen und das ist in einem normal
wasserbad einem normalen ein kochtopf
ein automat oder auch im backofen
übrigens nicht möglich weil wasser rein
physikalisch einfach nicht heißer als
100 grad kochen kann auch im backofen
nicht auch wenn dir noch 250 stellt also
müssen wir das ganze unter druck
einkochen dafür kann man entweder diese
speziellen druck einfach köpfe verwenden
oder auch einen druck kochtopf solange
der zufall es die temperaturen von über
116 grad erreicht da muss man also
unbedingt darauf achten dann vielleicht
auch modell nehmen dass ein bisschen
größer ist damit sich das auch lohnt
wenn ich immer drei gläser nacheinander
ein kocht und dann vielleicht doch mal
acht oder zehn stück daran stellen kann
dass es mir immer kann für wichtig weil
du sonst ewig dauert und dann könnt ihr
in so einem druck kochtopf einfach ganz
sicher zu hause bei euch die säure arm
lebensmitte so haltbar machen dass die
populismus bakterien keine chance mehr
haben eine frage die er häufig auf
gekommen ist ist die wie lange muss man
das ganze denn dann hüpfen damit das
ganze sicherheit fest und da scheinen
wir wieder hin zu andreas sich wie lange
man einen lebensmittel erhitzen muss
kann man pauschal gar nicht so sagen das
ist mal eine abhängigkeit von temperatur
und zeit also bei
121 grad das ist in der mikrobiologie
zum beispiel völlig normal eine völlig
normale temperatur bar überdruck da
braucht es
ja so etwa 20 minuten bevor wurde eine
500 milliliter konnte aber dann hat er
ist bei einer niedrigeren temperatur sie
zum beispiel 110 grad steigt die zeit
dann gleich deutlich an das
hauptanliegen war dann vom sofa circa 40
minuten genau also zeit und temperatur
spielen immer zusammen und es kommt auch
immer auf das lebensmittel an wie zum
beispiel die dichte ist wie gut die
temperaturen ins innere eindringen so
wie ich das verstanden genau das ist
richtig das ist das hängt davon ab wie
sehr flüssig und pastöse einige
lebensmittel ist oder als faustformel
kann man immer sagen wenn man eine suppe
zum beispiel in einem topf kochen kann
ohne dass sie an brennt dann ist die
konvektion in der flüssigkeit hat
ausreichen sodass sich die wärme
vernünftig verteilen kann wäre das so
dicht ist dass es halt anbrennen würde
dann bringt er ihnen auf die bühne
wichtig da da bringt auch einfach nicht
schnell genug ins innere
ist man beim einfrieren beim
kommentieren und beim einlegen in öl
auch darauf achten also können sich die
populismus bug day der haupt breit
machen und fangen wir mal mit dem
einfrieren an wir wissen ja die
botulismus tag stellen wir stehen voll
auf luftabschluss aber beim einfrieren
daher überall luft um unsere sachen der
hersteller normalerweise kein vakuum
außerdem sind die temperaturen so
niedrig dass bakterien sowieso wenn
schon nur sehr langsam irgendwas machen
deswegen ist eine absolut botulismus
sicher beim kommentieren
haben wir einen anderen vorteil da ist
zwar alles nicht allen gestand und wir
versuchen da auch im blase selber oder
im jahr top selber eine art
luftabschluss zu erreichen aber die
kleinen mädchen bakterien die da aktiv
sind das sind mal gut denn es geht ja
nicht nur schlecht in die produzieren ja
ganz viel milchsäure das heißt der ph
wert ist da so niedrig dass wir uns beim
kommentieren auch keine sorgen um
tourismus machen können jeden gespielt
allerdings ist dann als lägen in öl
keine sichere haltbar macht mehr tun
weil das wieder luftabschluss bedeutet
wenn wir das so chilischoten zum
beispiel in das öl wagen schmeißen dann
sind ja auch wieder von der luft
abgeschlossen das öl und mantel die und
dann können sich die populismus
bakterien auch in öl eingelegten
lebensmitteln ausbreiten deswegen ist
ein regen in öl eigentlich keine sichere
alba macht methode eine andere frage ist
kann man durch zugabe von zitronensäure
das milieu so verändern dass botulismus
zb bei bohnen keine chance hat so dass
man normal einkaufen kann wenn man zum
beispiel keinen druck kochtöpfe zu hause
hat das ist möglich und das ist auch
super praktisch dass das geht ich würde
dafür aber immer essig nehmen weil das
irgendwie irqa schmeckt als
zitronensäure aber zb in meinem
gemüsegarten boot camp das ist ein
kostenloser kurz zum einkochen und halte
machen der ernte den ich jedem sommer
liebe da haben wir auch ein rezept wo
man zucchini ein kochen kann da habe ich
einfach essig mit dazu gegeben das sind
super leckere süße sorgen zucchini die
man dann am ende der ein kocht und da
ist der ph-wert zum beispiel auch so
niedrig dass man das in einem ganz
normalen kochtopf oder einen kochtopf
ein kochen kann und nicht unter druck
machen muss da muss man dann aber auch
darauf achten dass das ganze wirklich
sauber genug ist und im zweifel einfach
ein sicheres rezept verwenden aus einer
quelle der man vertraut wo man weiß dass
diese verbindung mit botulismus
auseinandergesetzt hat weil der ph-wert
im glas natürlich trotzdem unter dieser
45 grenze liegen muss ist es kein
problem solange man eben die sicheren
rezepte verwendet und das ist auch beim
einkochen im kochtopf super wichtig dass
man sich da an sichere rezepte heldt wir
haben das problem mit meinem online kurs
wo ich ja ganz viele rezepte den leuten
mit an die hand geben möchte damit man
alles was vom garten irgendwie in die
küche kommt sicherheit bei machen kann
und wenn wir dafür neue rezepte
entwickeln da müssen wir die von einem
experten prüfen lassen also das ist
wirklich kompliziert weil es da als wir
auf die dichte und so weiter ankommt und
jedes lebensmittel anders reagiert sich
die sporen in jedem lebensmittel anders
verhalten können und dazu andreas war
noch mehr erzählt ich noch mal was er
dazu gesagt hat es leider nicht so schön
euch das sagen zu müssen aber auch
selber mit rezepten
herumzuexperimentieren ist beim druck
einkochen er nicht so angesagt weil man
da so viel beachten muss wenn man
rezepte entwickelt das das als laie sehr
schwierig ist leider genau ja leider ja
da kommt es darauf an was für einen
salzgehalt hat man hinterher war für ein
ph-wert hat man
in der der fertigen konserve sage ich
jetzt mal dann kommt das wie gesagt
darauf an wie passt es ist das ganz sind
eventuell irgendwelche bestandteile
darin die halt fetthaltig sind und es
kommt auch unter anderem darauf an was
für gemüse packe ich da letztendlich
rein wie für bodenkontakt hatten die das
muss alles mit bedacht werden das
rechtlich eine gute ihn einfach macht
super viel spaß und so lange man weiß
was man tut wenn sich einer mit dem
thema buddhismus beschäftigt hat es ist
auch gar kein problem jedes lebensmittel
was irgendwie die küche kommen sicher
heilbar zu machen
danke nochmal an andreas dass du da
warst du ich meinen fragen gestellt hat
er hat auch einen youtube kanal der
macht nämlich ganz krasse feuershows
also da auf jeden fall bahrain schon
wenn euch das interessiert mega
beeindruckend ich verlinke ich auf jeden
fall mal irgendwo hier und unsere hell
video beschreibung und dann geht raus
nach die welt ein bisschen grüner wir
sehen unseren dank sagte ich bin ein
idiot